regresar a Irlanda del Norte como
presidente estuvo en los planes de Joe
biden hace mucho más teniendo en cuenta
que es católico y de origen Irlandés
como lo fue también el expresidente John
F Kennedy antes de partir a belfas
capital de Irlanda del Norte donde se
reunirá entre otros con el Primer
Ministro del Reino Unido Richie sunak
dijo que el objetivo de este viaje era
asegurarse que los acuerdos irlandeses
entre ellos el acuerdo del viernes Santo
firmado en 1998 y el acuerdo de Witcher
se mantengan para asegurar la paz entre
la República de Irlanda e Irlanda del
Norte Pero hay disputas sobre reglas
comerciales entre el Reino Unido y la
Unión Europea la que pertenece la
República de Irlanda y esto ha puesto a
prueba el acuerdo del viernes santo que
Estados Unidos ayudó a intermediar tras
negociaciones sin embargo el actual
Primer Ministro del Reino Unido y Richie
sunak llegó a un acuerdo para resolver
la disputa comercial en febrero Pero el
principal partido político unionista de
Irlanda del Norte aún no ha firmado la
resolución de esta disputa Así que
resolver estos problemas comerciales que
se originaron desde el brexit para
conmemorar el aniversario número 25 del
acuerdo del viernes Santo será uno de
los objetivos principales de la visita
de Joe biden a Irlanda